today
I have anxious chakra but I'm okay okay
cool
I gotta bang a store to tell you later
okay I clicked live I don't know about
the Live point all right
I was like I was waiting for you it's
like it's like I should have quit yeah
all right weeps waves we are a lot Ohio
hello everybody
watching a lot of Terry's house recently
how's it going Griffin how's it going
everybody it's me Albert with Griffin
and with Alex Friedman
you're in the chat right that's right
right
how are we doing guys with a less good
looking not good looking wow lights I'm
not saying you're not good looking I'm
just saying that your lights are [ __ ] uh
hold up hold up hold up okay okay okay
all right
welcome so glad that you are a new
subscriber so boys what anime are we
gonna be talking about today energy
energy energy is not an enemy that's
true that's true no what are we talking
about
uh we're gonna talk about that you know
if you don't watch yourself when you're
eating that tasty Fruit Street food in
Thailand you can catch yourself a
parasite part two hey I wasn't sure how
you were gonna segue that but you did
right okay
who wants to start off the discussion on
parasite Mal do you want to start uh so
this happened to me when I was swimming
in at the Amazon no okay what
no do you know the parasite no the
parasite in the Amazons the the one that
uh jumps up that swims up your uh thing
back disgusting absolutely
what's up guys thank you yeah we're
doing parasite part two we did parasite
part one like a few months ago
uh it was it used to be one of my
favorite mangas I was sad that it wasn't
able to turn into an anime and then they
did they made an economy like recently
when did you read the Manga when I was
like younger it was like when I was in
Middle School okay I can't remember yeah
how's it going everyone uh Andy Tech
legendary how's it going guys hey a Novo
killer skeleton oh
alrighty so you mentioned the manga um
does because when I was looking into
parasite face like they were talking
about how the manga the Artistry of the
manga like the era was like slightly
older is that true oh yeah you can tell
from they like modernized it yeah can't
you tell from the haircut of the main
guy he looks like Don
oh I mean Dom looks quite a bit better
no no I mean the era of the manga was
like it uh it's the same haircut as YuYu
Hakusho if you remember oh that guy love
him will that be like what the like uh
select back hair bits 80s early 90s 80s
and 90s kind of era I can't remember if
I'm right but you want a parasite like
the one that MC has IRL I like my
pregnancy and I think a parasite will
jeopardize that
on me
but yeah I was like how do you guys like
the anime yeah sorry I think voice box
man
go voice box man voice box man we'll go
I like it I think it's pretty good
um
what I didn't like well actually let me
rewind
I actually think it reminds me it's it's
kind of similar to I feel like Tokyo
Ghoul
if you think about it you got these
other species that are apparently
Superior to humans but they're in the
background and they're slowly trying to
both in both stories take over like
mainstream both take over like the
uh visible world
and both of them have like this weird
parasite or this something that's living
inside of them with uh kaneki it was uh
oh dude what was Rin was it was it I
can't remember the girl's name we always
called her purple Hill girl but um which
is very much a thing but I don't know I
feel like they both try to sort of
coexist what I think Tokyo Ghoul did
better than uh say parasite was that it
just it was for one I felt like more
scary
the anime itself didn't really get me
scared it was I felt more just more
action than uh for parasite parasite
yeah for parasite yeah for parasite
that's kind of
Gigi yes I I'm Kirito yes Gigi that's
one of my tank teams you know anyway
what I'm afraid of is that that among
this guy will come back
oh no wait is this one Among Us guys
Phil what's up man hey how you doing
just playing around with the emoticons
it's fine but yeah it's like I feel like
uh
Tokyo Ghoul just stepped up the
storyline even though it's like similar
but not really kind of similar just the
difference between them and as the goals
are a virus and the parasite came from
space I kind of forgot
uh person came up from space but we
don't really we don't really know if
they reproduced if they like
get out more you know
or and at the end of it it didn't the
girl
uh I can't remember her name ryoko ryoko
ryoko tindericoke had a baby and then I
found out that baby's not not a parasite
so parasites will just die with their
yeah they can they can like you know do
it with each other but then like a human
will come out yeah a normal human so
that's pretty interesting
that a human will come out all right
I think I think um I think with Tokyo
Ghoul the huge difference was was that
the universe itself set itself up so
that they had to kind of tell how
like the ghouls already coexisted with
the the humans and they had the wards
and some Wards a more ghoul-infested
whereas like parasite it's just kind of
a virus just comes in and starts
replicating you know what I mean right
yeah
I feel like the intro could have been
more interesting because like they're
coming down as like a freaking little
like uh almost like little snowballs or
snowflakes or little
I don't know like pollen or something
just floating down
I'm like yeah something a little more
dramatic would have been sweet I mean
totally when migi went up went up his
nose I was like okay that's that's the
best stealth way though and all like the
other movies and [ __ ] the aliens always
coming in I'm like Armageddon style and
all that this is like sneaky
skeleton I know right anime horror
sometimes is not that scary tell me
about it I think Tokyo go Tokyo Google
Tokyo Google gaga
I'm the voice guy and I can't even speak
words
um
I don't know but like but you also have
to remind yourself that this was like a
90s 80s kind of manga so it's like oh
okay okay you're right it's like the
writing is probably not as scary they
probably didn't figure out most of the
story beforehand and then they ended it
really I heard the manga was actually
way more like Gory for them the anime
yeah right the same way as Tokyo Ghoul
the manga is like way more Courier
there's a better story in the manga than
the anime of Tokyo Ghoul the Art's a bit
better and stuff like that but you know
20 something
I don't remember weeps let us know
thank you Christopher always love the
love appreciate it
it was very funny though I love the
intro that bit that we did just to brag
on our video which you should go check
out is you know so like shinichi he's
got two chicks and so he loses one right
killer bro what I know he's already got
two checks it's like what are you
talking about
about being sad even though he's too
timing the girl so hard
yeah
I know brutal I was kind of rooting for
her over the the main one but will you
wearing
what yeah why were you rooting for her
versus the other one uh I just you know
I just felt more like
you know what I mean for the the one
that died I don't know what it is I felt
some like Spice in there
the main one she was just too like
it's like white rice you know like it's
all right I can eat it but do I love it
I don't know
hey saying a meal Tokyo Ghoul was 12 to
16 episodes if he remembers correctly
thank you
so what do we think of the very ending
of parasite did it like actually it just
kind of like okay I was quite surprised
like they fought off the main dude uh
goto right and he was like this op God
and then somehow
you know that ex machina one where Miki
like Miki came back and like helped him
and all that [ __ ] I'll allow it but then
it's like six months later or whatever
they brought me the creepy face and
that's the ending I'm like ah this was
kind of unnecessary to be honest you
know what I mean yeah
I was quite surprised they decided to
end it that way
Al is that the same in the manga I think
it's the same I think he saved the he
saved the girlfriend because the uh he
saved the girlfriend and from being
pushed off a building and it was really
rough it's still I think it's supposed
to be more kind of sad
because they were they had they had gone
through this tough times with like with
the bad guy with goto with like ryoko
and all the other [ __ ] and then they
were finally been able to like kind of
become friends or get together in some
way or they're like they figure out how
to how where they stand as a yeah as a
human team or as a thing and then uh
migi uses up his final power and then he
had to go on full hibernation and we
don't know if he ever gonna wakes up
yeah so it was supposed to be a little
bit more somber but they really
they really just edited really quickly
yeah that's why I like that's what I
like for that ending I was like you know
what this does it's not even warranted
putting a beat about like how to beat
creepy face because it's like it's so
lackluster that last scene so I was just
like ah [ __ ] it just ended
do we think that um
because I was doing a whole comparison
ghoul and parasite do you feel like
parasite characters were like pretty
well fleshed out or were they basically
like they gave you just enough so they
could tell you what was happening you
kind of know the characters and then
move on because that's what I think they
felt kind of like there was no real
depth to them parasite yeah
I think so I think I think it was
supposed to be I think mango as it was
originally gonna be like a monster of
parasite of the week kind of thing
oh if I remember correctly someone might
say I was wrong
but uh back in those days back in my day
all right 80s 90s manga they didn't
really do a lot of storyline anime they
just do a lot of story of the week kind
of [ __ ] so
what is that for the for the non-weed
weebs story of the week is that like
just a short quick thing just to like
like any TV show though oh okay cool
like a procedure yeah okay
cool cool
uh legendary that's a great [ __ ] idea
anime quiz podcast
you know I might not actually bro
I I don't know do parrot no what what is
it what'd you say anime quiz anime quiz
podcast
were you writing Paris and parasite
no no I was writing anime quiz things
you said parasite that on his mouth
sometimes goes like what my brain
doesn't want to you know oh brother Dr
magic born says dude I watched circus
Kane and put myself into it and used
your logic and survived so thanks I
guess you're welcome you lived uh I
couldn't even remember it's been a while
oh it's been a long time uh it's been a
long time it's been like a week since
I've seen that anime
apparently all right God damn it uh but
yeah I was like are you guys uh do you
enjoy it I think I do enjoy Tokyo a
little bit more than parasite and it's
like manga form but it's still
holds a place in my heart for being one
of the earlier mangas that I've read or
anime anime probably not really but
Monica wise
I
I am I don't know I'm a fan I'm a fan of
Tokyo Ghoul pretty much all the way
quite a bit more than parasite that's
just me what do you think Tom
you think the first part of parasite was
A1 second part was like it's all right I
feel like the first part was more
exploring the the whole parasite you
know cohabitating with the human host
thing but the second part was more
action but the fact that it already
wasn't as scary as something like Tokyo
Ghoul kinda lost me a little bit because
the action was kind of cool but like it
wasn't like super
bow in your face type scariness you know
what I mean right oh this is a great
idea sane Emil says just imagine
parasite and Tokyo Ghoul Universe living
together it would be such a mess to deal
with him that's kind of like you know
Freddy versus Jason like who would win
yeah like
that would be interesting
that would be really interesting that'd
be crazy right but would the Alien
Parasite be able to take over a ghoul
hmm
uh probably most likely probably yeah
probably you just get them when they're
sleeping bro
well that sucks to be like the only
reason why our boys tinichi shinichi
sinichi got his yeah like got saved was
because he was wearing headphones
whether he was asleep
oh yeah that's true that's true
oh he's freaking out
was there closure on um ryoko's baby I
can't I think no they just gave it away
yeah gave the baby away and the baby was
human so you know kind of yeah no one
gives you useless yeah
we all know that baby is going to be
like probably in a lab somewhere 100 I
should have written something in there
like ryoko gives a baby probably to be
caught up into little pieces something
you know what I mean damn it
last opportunity
all right I know
the police the government's kind of
shitty the police department's kind of
[ __ ]
yeah it was like this is our way of
defeating the aliens we're gonna kill
everyone let's see what the [ __ ] there's
no pushback oh yeah I remember that well
Captain's stud face was like leading the
whole thing so I mean you can't go up
against him he's wearing a three-piece
suit
not during the race
well yeah I know but like when he was in
the bureaucracy office rooms and all
that [ __ ] you know talking to the dudes
certainly was a very Snappy suit just
like the one that our very own writer is
wearing oh my only so far for sure
I saw like I saw some I saw a YouTube
short talking about getting a like a
good suit and shirt in Thailand for like
200 bucks or something
was it the one by the the Latin guy the
American life I think he's not like
Americans like somewhat it's like Asian
looking like I wasn't even looking at
his face he just thoughts like oh I have
a big bicep and that's how uh and then
they gave me a record for having the
biggest bicep Fighters no I don't I
literally saw a similar thing like a
couple of days ago but I think it's so
much cheaper the Fabric's good I really
like the shirt and then I made an
overcoat and I was like all right I made
a three-piece soon and overcome for like
300 400 bucks I was like God damn I
should send this to Dom but I forgot
where it was and it's related but yeah
good [ __ ] over here I love the channel
keep with the good work but yeah it's
like Crazy Girlfriend diary versus crazy
girl from King's game
which one is crazy girl from King's game
part two
yeah I really can't remember
where she cut up her friends and [ __ ]
yeah pretty sure it was oh and she
chainsawed the everyone else
because she's like I love you and they
will die together ah she yeah that was
early that was pretty rough but for sure
that was a month ago oh my gosh
this don't see Builder you were not late
we're just shooting the shite
indeed from the side we were talking
about parasite though I feel like we
might dabble into other topics should we
do that my good Gents
possibly I'm not sure let's see oh fun
fact I saw a little thing because I was
watching parasite because you don't like
to gather up some notes so that we have
things to talk about I got a little blip
of a notification saying that the second
half or one of the spyex family the
second half of it has already come out
and that the last few episodes are in
route ow you watch Spy X family right I
watched the first half I can't remember
I I actually saw like two minutes of it
the other day
why two minutes of it I was uh at a
friend's house and then they put it on
for like a couple minutes and I was like
oh I have seen this oh get the [ __ ] out
of my face
you know what you said probably
so get this [ __ ] out of my friend I want
to see someone working out get a ribs
tell us and the non-webs are people who
don't know about it what is the story
about it does look interesting I haven't
watched this by ex-family uh it's about
a kid who it's about a dad not a dad but
a spy who had to make a cover by uh
making make a cover by meeting like a
like a like a parent of like a kid who
goes to like a very pretty prestigious
school so then he had to it's like oh
I'm single as [ __ ] I have to find a kid
so he adopts this kid and apparently
this kid has psychic powers psychic
powers by bisexuality she can hear
people telepathically
um she's able to read people's minds so
whenever uh her dad the Spy was trying
to like uh test her on her knowledge she
just reads his mind for the dancers like
can you do this like yeah it's like I
just read it read his minds and then he
gets she gets all the answers right and
everything she gets adopted and then he
meets uh he meets uh he has to find a
wife because apparently it's a very
conservative really conservative school
where everyone has to be your parent to
parent house and then you can't have you
can't be divorced or it's weird it's
like it's weird it's a weird way yeah
and then she finds a new wife and then
that wife is apparently it's also like a
like an assassin
who's an assassin the wife the the white
wife was the secret assassin so it's
like a spy and an assassin and a girl
with psychic powers and then later they
find a dog if I know about the the wife
no one knows anything the only one that
knows it's the girl because she's able
to read everyone's mind right
um
smile is uh gets married to an assassin
a girl uh the girl who has telepathic
Powers the Assassin has like a KGB agent
brother
okay it's like a like a governmental
like FBI or some sort brother and also
they adopted a dog that is able to uh
that is able to see the future or
somehow it's funny it's great it's very
wholesome and funny people should watch
it reminds me of a little bit of like a
cross between uh the Americans a story
about like a KGB family going to America
and pretending to be a family in the
1980s and across with um you know Vin
Diesel's The Pacifier when he like
starts he looks out after those kids and
he's like
he's like a spy agent
or
Mr and Mrs Smith but with a psychic kid
yeah okay see I never seen him
you've never seen me it's pretty solid
it bums me out that because of that
movie uh Brad Pitt broke up with 10 of
France right
back I mean have you seen that movie the
man can only hold out for so long
I mean the thing is they got married for
a long time they were married for a long
time yeah back in it just the message
for like 20 20 years or something
yeah well and then they broke up again
so it's weird yeah that's Hollywood
oh
thank you versus Asta who you all think
gong win uh do you know who hasta is
Griffin
I do oh you do damn I don't know what
you're gonna ask me no because I know
you don't you don't even know who Deku
is you don't know yeah but I saw the
Brad Pitt at Astra like two years ago
that was pretty good it's not even the
same one what is that correlate okay it
sounded familiar
[Laughter]
um hmm
uh parasite
anything else should we talk about
parasite or what
uh was there season two like there's not
there's only two it's one season right
it's one season it's a short that's a
short and sweet kind of animal oh
interesting okay didn't know that
uh yes I mean
I suppose you have one more thing on
parasite that's about it for me what is
it where I will tell you so I guess the
whole idea behind parasite is like what
is humanity you know I mean like I guess
that's maybe the message it tries to put
out you know like what does it mean to
be human or
have like some sort of moral compass do
you guys
I have to cut out a lot of that moral
Quantum type [ __ ] for the sake of the
story but yeah they talk a lot about
that in the anime
cut out the moral Quantum yeah because
it's it's good to watch but not good too
when you have to make it scary
and number one dude um one dude I saw a
comment for uh Akira he was like why is
this dude trying to make everything
sound scary
it's just funny
yeah that's kind of our deal yeah
like kind of what we do
um and that's all that I got for
parasite what do you guys got
what I've been thinking right because
first parasite
um I think I've stopped it at 11
episodes or something so it was maybe
28 minutes long the actual YouTube video
or something but then because the second
parasite you know is up to like 22
Episodes of some [ __ ] or 23 or some [ __ ]
so the the episodes for the second part
were longer so the video in itself was
pretty [ __ ] long it was like 35
minutes or some [ __ ] so it got me
thinking how much
anime type videos that we do is a good
perfect length that the weaves want to
see that's not too short not too long
the soul station I remember was like 18
minutes that was pretty short
yeah some of it like Tokyo Ghoul or
something else was like [ __ ] or devil
man cry baby was that like 45 45
yeah
it was a long one too hey theological
really
he's nice
all right I need to give her a Rockstar
Energy toast not sponsored yet what and
we're sending back the money it just
went relaxed I couldn't even see it
because Tom did that we're sending back
the money because that was Queen just
walk
I'm getting up toast
kidding okay thank you so much thank you
so much
thank you that is so kind of you if you
have a question we will answer it to the
best of our ability uh what the [ __ ] was
this thing oh yeah uh what's a good like
what's the perfect anime lent because
I'm also really trying to these days
weebs I'm trying to I'm trying to put a
word count on all the scripts to make
all the the anime [ __ ] or certain
you know video length so I'm just it's
got me thinking what do you guys think
what are you weaves what is too long of
an anime video for you weebs uh one for
like our type of content
yeah okay okay yes
I'm saying it's too long it's not saying
it's perfect length
um okay
uh mostly because they probably caught
up with the manga a lot and they had to
add a lot of filler in between uh a lot
of the times but uh but I think but I
think they got better I need to watch it
too I was like I hear bleach was the new
season of bleach is apparently it's
really really good according to my
friends who uh recently watched it
Naruto is also one of those uh but
perfect length is probably
two three seasons uh Dom's taking a
photo of that person giving us a
donation to show off to his friends no
it's the first one bro first one I'm
just messing I'm kidding actually now I
feel like I have to do it I'm also gonna
take a photo that's really sweet I'm
going to that was very nice oh that's
all let's all take selfies no I'm not
gonna take a selfie we're basically in a
selfie dump we're literally recording
myself
get back
on we're talking about all right okay uh
length of the anime episodes what do we
think because we're asking our weebs
what is a good length of anime video for
how to be a video what do you think is a
good length do let us know is it 30
minutes 36 45 minutes you mean like less
than like one episode or length that's
in like oh yeah so like the type of
videos how to be videos that we do on
YouTube what's a video that is too like
too [ __ ] long and what is a good
length that we think everybody would not
mind watching you know investing 25
minutes 30 minutes to watch a how to
beat video
honestly it depends on the topic uh 40
minutes legendary all right you've
already managed legendary yes
legendary
I think our latest video Whatever
parasite was like what was it 36 minutes
36 minutes
and Bobcat was like whining was like bro
why'd you make it so long and I was like
bro I tried to cut as much [ __ ] as I
could you could have cut more oh my God
gosh yeah as you don't understand Dom's
like talking he's like oh maybe we could
like try to do this this like I don't
know it's it's tough 30 minutes Paulette
that is uh somebody uh our goal to cut
it down to 30 minutes
and then there were two
that's right
okay
I saw a chat earlier that intrigued me
and I need someone to get me a
screenshot of it random fact that you
all know that in some countries that
attack on Titan uh the titans in Attack
on Titan are blurred and some of them
have pants
what yeah we should have done a bad
version of it bro we should have done
that one oh someone's gonna send it to
me bro I need to see us at the door oh
that is so weird why would they do that
oh we missed you too oh God we missed
you now put this bobcat in his place
wow now we've honestly found that 30
minutes is I think the sweet spot now
I'm literally like as soon as um I I
think what is it made in Abyss I think
that was 30 minutes or some [ __ ] so I'm
literally putting a word count before I
start the script x amount of words and
like I need to [ __ ] hit that [ __ ] I'm
done with these 45 minute videos Lads
done
weebs you don't understand this guy dumb
when he started he's like oh how am I
gonna get to 30 minutes I don't know if
I can do it and then he goes way past
until like 40 minutes here how do I get
it done to 15 minutes what the [ __ ] did
I do it before yeah guys yeah all right
now because our producer was like stop
you gotta like make it longer bro and
I'm like but how do I do that and then I
think I was like you know what I'm gonna
show him I'm gonna show that dude and
then I [ __ ] did it with devil man cry
baby or some shoes oh no uh dead man
Wonderland the initial one was like I
think 12 000 words or some [ __ ] and I
was like I think I've I've blown my load
I gotta cut back yeah that was funny
that was a good time okay so mine is
that blowing the load spot um how did
you feel after
how did you feel were you look I'm dead
you know yeah it was so much [ __ ]
work and even the beats and [ __ ] like I
know yeah honestly the Beats I think
were the
I think back then also our style was
that so I put in
like 18 beats or some [ __ ] in one script
so it'd just be a ton of [ __ ] just
like oh
you know I remember for one of them I
think initially I had like 17 it was for
like um inuyashiki or something
initially I had like 17 beats or
something but now I'm like I cut you
know [ __ ] this [ __ ] we're gonna keep it
short and sweet and tasty so now I think
we do like I think seven eight beats
these days
but yeah that was a roller coaster
for sure oh that was too funny
what do you I don't know I feel like
um yeah 30 and 35 minutes is a good one
for sure it's like in terms of length in
terms of episodes
uh I mean usually we always break it up
into you know first half second half now
so it really
doesn't matter too much you know now I
feel like obviously like one piece or
like Naruto or bleach or even if we ever
did touch one of those those are the
ones we definitely like we've asked in
previous streams let us know the story
arc of for in terms of those if you want
to do a video about those how to beat
video let us know the arc because those
are super long we can't do like 500
episode videos see I know like you know
I mean I'll be the biggest weeb even
though I'm the weeb king but like I feel
like some of these 25 episode animes
this is so much you know it's like one
of those TV shows that have like 30
episodes come on episode you know 24
we're gonna forget what happened on
episode two
you know what I mean
what's the shittiest uh thing that dance
watch in front of me I can't remember a
shitty TV show on Netflix I can't
remember peaky blinders watch that
[ __ ] mouth raylen
I'm trying to I'm trying to figure out
what it's like a real I was like reality
TV shows maybe oh love it I appreciate
you we love Island I do I do what's up
love Island uh who watches that what is
that you do
yeah I know but it's research it's
research is it for what it's social
dynamics and they're like the
interconnection can you watch it through
love Island where it's heightened up to
like a 15.
yeah but you know you got to watch you
got to watch all forms of uh study
before you can make an assessment about
uh you know the study of mankind and 25
episodes too long
um
I'll be honest on those shows too I've
noticed by like episode 14 I'm like all
right I'm kind of like kind of getting a
little bit bored but like the the short
like eight episode 12 episodes sweet
spot I think just in general bro
we can't do everything on Naruto all
right you need to stop what happened
give us an arc
we're not doing everything
great PSP game I played one time good
stuff
um
I never played any of the Naruto video
games
I'm pretty sick
no I did Full Metal Alchemist though any
weebs out there play the Full Metal
Alchemist video game let me know we did
do that one back on uh what console was
there in 1985
right
no it was a 1960s uh Dom was being uh
generous about your age right
hey I look good for being that oh geez
Fair like real old let's see oh so weebs
as you all know Bobcat our Bobcat loves
manga he loves manga so much so he one
time fell yeah on his face and he's and
he kept reading he kept reading
that's a very true story so anyway yes
they do have a game it's super old
according
fair enough all right all right anyways
I was looking up some things because I
was looking for something new to read
we're all very busy nowadays and I was
like what would be a good manga to read
because I like reading you know webtoons
or mangas and stuff too wait not as much
as hell he's like nerd he's way up there
huh
what are we doing for a living this is
the most nerdiest stuff we could do I
know what you mean I just come on the
podcast and hang out
way
what I thought was really interesting
have you heard of the a manga called
Children of the whales
that sounds cute as [ __ ]
that sounds dark kind of usually when
they name it really cute they they're
dark that's true actually it so I was
like children of the whales
it's like maybe we could do hey good
morning clutch power good morning clutch
power
Chadwick exactly
yeah same for children about men
children of whales what children of
whales if you don't know what it is I'll
kind of read the a very brief bit of the
description right so it starts out with
an Endless Sea of sand drifts the mud
whale a floating island city of clay and
magic and its Chambers a small community
that clings to survival most dying Young
from the very powers that sustain them
yeah I did go to Voice Box Mode but it
looks so interesting because it's like
about these people trying to survive on
this magic but the very old magic that
keeps them alive is the thing that's
killing them and I'm just like this
looks so freaking interesting I want to
read it hey clutch power
children of Wales is so good oh [ __ ] you
read it hey all right
I haven't read what the [ __ ] damn Bobcat
I'm losing my Powers I'm losing my
powers and with that I'm losing my hair
and that's why today we're sponsored by
I'll be sick that would be amazing
it just it looked really good it looked
really good
Dom have have you read any manga ever
no he's a [ __ ] hey
I'm sorry they came out of nowhere
I'm gonna put the paws away uh honestly
I don't think so I think I meant to do
it one time at a friend's house but then
for some reason
he had an origami book and I knew he was
really good at doing origami and like I
was at that age where I was trying to
make a new friend so I was like let's do
some origami instead you can teach me
stuff so we bonded over that long story
short I was going to one time but I
didn't
origami God
origami got in the way uh you should
read The Boxers there's a lot of good
boxing manga out there uh Hajime no ippo
it's really fun if you like Old School
Boxing um it's like a thousand it has
like a thousand chapters in
by a thousand I mean like 100 volumes of
Monk pieces it's nuts uh I think if you
want to go something that's like
classically classic in a way that it's
very easy to digest it's like all about
defeating a bad guy uh Powers magic
there's one called ragna Crimson dragons
where the bad guys are all dragons and
they're trying to take it down and
dragons are like controlling the world
and [ __ ] it's really cool it's really
fun oh
but yeah uh I'll read that Griffin
Children of the whales uh yeah
anything anime related
don't have you seen anything other than
work have you seen anything else
uh
uh what is it the Texas Chainsaw man no
the chainsaw man
I was literally I was literally doing
work today and then I was on Discord
with some boys and then they were like
screen sharing this [ __ ] so I actually
watched some um chainsaw man for like a
couple minutes this dude was on this big
ass bat or something dude was trying to
take a bite out of the bat or some [ __ ]
uh so I watched I watched a little bit
of that that feels like those five
minutes oh my God it started like
oh that's so good that's such a good
manga too a coach power have you any of
you read just you got no Roku then
uh
[Laughter]
uh Griffin if you haven't seen it or
read it it's about I I know Dom but I'm
not addressing you mostly because you
[ __ ] never will read it oh will you
why what are you talking about uh the
one that coach Paul was talking about
okay give me the give me the elevator
pitch 15 seconds what's the anime about
get the non-web into it so this guy is
being bullied by five kids all right I
know uh apparently this bully is so
messed up that he find like the way he
wants to make this kid miserable he
kills his parents and makes his brother
in a coma puts his brother coma through
an accident so they yeah
and then after that this guy wants to
get revenge and then he it's a story
about his revenge and it's messed up I
know how he gets all of his revenge
that's it okay that's pretty good pretty
good they're never gonna make an anime
out of it it's too messed up
it's too [ __ ] up yeah
like how
uh no I mean like the guy when he takes
Revenge he does it in like a torture
porny kind of way
oh what what okay
he just heard porn don't just hear his
porn no I literally like what did you
say uh he does it in a torture porny
kind of
ways
oh okay okay no that's not why uh no I'm
just messing with you honestly at some
point though if we venture like if we
start doing the how to beats but then I
don't know do something with
it's super good it's super dark and it's
kind of sad because you see this guy
losing his like trying his best to keep
it together about uh uh about losing his
family and [ __ ] and then now it's like
trying to get well we got nerd explain
Cinema summary and these guys I'll be
crazy uh what happened yeah we got
another explains and these guys I'll be
oh maybe he means he'll be like crazy
busy is that what you mean legendary or
something I don't know no it explains
pretty good I like him too how to beat
him all uh how to beat YouTubers are in
one death game just imagine
this suit
covered in Black I don't know at the end
of it honestly I'll just uh side with
whoever the bigger subscribers
that's fair I'll share part of the
YouTube game Alice Shield I was like who
the [ __ ] is this These Guys these losers
cut them out baby
who's this cat
and then that way I'll be a double
double agent right and then after that I
[ __ ] them up
no that's fair oh obviously after I [ __ ]
them up and we'll get uh we'll get their
subscribers because I know the winner is
going to get all the subscribers that's
how it that would be a good [ __ ]
YouTube death game thing the winner gets
all the other subscribers
[ __ ] glorious I'll be sick
uh uh out of curiosity are you related
to India in any way
uh yes I'm uh half Indian but raised
primarily in Bangkok Thailand
for the most part
and his address is
oh my dress is one two Mango Street
if there is a one two Mango Street I'll
die oh man you're gonna be able to
showing up your house or your place oh
my gosh
that part yeah and I was thinking like
if there was an actually one two mangoes
like Mango Street called mango I'd live
there bro
the Korean manga or uh Chinese manga
see uh I do get into them I just don't
not a big I don't have a big preference
for a lot of the Chinese manga why not
explain yourself I don't know the
stories feels a bit too much like uh
Power like uh
it's like I want Power for the sake of
power kind of situation and most of the
stories like the guy is a dick and then
the bad guy has to be a bigger dick so
it's like the main guy's like a major
like douchebag in a way and so the bad
guy has to be a bigger douchebag because
you can't have like you know and there's
no Redemption Arc everyone's like a bad
bad guy it's always black and white it's
kind of boring in a way and it always
escalates in this like power levels and
[ __ ] it's kind of boring it's like it
gets interesting that's funny
which is
how does the best okay yeah go go for a
script
no no you go you go I've been thinking
what's the best anime
for non-web wannabe weebs to start
weebing into
I love it but like for like noobs who
don't really like anime or like you know
what's the best like you know dip your
toe in the thing don't just jump into
the the water
hear what Al said love Island
we're gonna do it more soon later
it ended like they were so ready for a
second season bro oh there is a second
season but I don't remember if we split
them out oh [ __ ] no I don't think we did
I thought we only did the the one it
wasn't that that's why there was like
long as [ __ ] the the episode I mean the
the video right yeah I believe so
yeah maybe yeah uh Attack on Titan
naturally of course yeah I was gonna I
was gonna say like the the non-weave
type anime
the worst
High School of the Dead Andy that was
literally the shite
one of the most fun times writing that
script
oh here we go legendary your line April
is a good f-starter oh that's a good one
just cry
what is it what is it run down 15
seconds go go here we go a boy and a
girl a girl who plays the piano and a
boy who plays the violin and the boy
doesn't want to play violin anymore and
they became good friends they'd start a
thing and then the girl has a sickness
and you have to figure out if she dies
or she lives at the end of the day
did you just say oh hero age is that do
you mean heroic age or hero age because
last live stream I love that anime
heroic age or do you mean hero age I'm
guessing it's heroic age
do another collab with Cinema summary
they keep destroying our video on the
clouds in our summary
how to beat uh we have re-uploaded it
and then they [ __ ] destroyed it
hopefully we'll do one more one more
uh we'll talk to how to beat and we'll
see what happens
yeah
they're cool we like them we like oh
clutch power Death Note actually was one
of my Dart animes too
oh my friend was like you know you'll
like this anime and so I watch I watch
it I got up to like 15 episodes or
something I was like yeah that's a
pretty good ship that's a good start
anime
hey thank you Bobcat happy anime that's
very nice that's very nice I'm not sure
I'll let them know I let them I'll let
Cinema summary know about that I'll take
a screenshot
hell yeah bro so get ready okay what's
the best anime
what's the best anime for like the most
artsy fartsy of weebs so like what's the
best anime for Bobcat like these type
like full-on Wii nerd type you know well
then all right first of all I mean in a
good way I'm the weed King come on I'm
the king of yours okay well we got the
what would it be
okay would it be paprika
no don't they will cancel me
we'll see we'll see if they jump into
chat and try to destroy you in the chat
all right anyways
um let's see best anime for the most
anime lovers like the anime purists of
whatever [ __ ] the one's really into
anime what's the what's what are some
like really good animes death notes that
are not like mainstream okay oh not
mainstream uh probably paprika I think
was it paprika was the hey I've got some
of that in my cabinet
boom Oh
code geese code yes
sorry whatever
what close enough
oh Code Geass uh it's really good okay
apparently they had like a very [ __ ] a
very good season one and then they have
a very bad season too but a very good
ending
can't remember I haven't seen it Helsing
Bento
[Music]
um
I watch anime where all the characters
end up dealing dying it was Angel can't
remember the rest it's probably
all the characters dying
platinum's end or something it sounds
like a little man cry baby ending or
something
Demon Slayer is pretty easy to get into
uh yeah it's very pretty uh other card
is a beast
oh so good because I think Dom would
like that one cookie I think he would
like healthy yeah
I think Dawn will get into it he'll sing
Helsing oh yeah
you like those those would be pretty
good Grim Cuddy yeah okay no it's
whatever I think simmer summary made it
they did something about that yeah about
that yeah
have y'all watched death ain't no I've
seen Charlie's Angels I'm gonna go watch
high-rise Invasion all right you can
watch it uh you can watch it it's on our
Channel
yes please do things a funny ass show
it's funny
what's that about I don't know I think
it's like a
it's a isekai show so it's like a
comedic take of like uh they don't take
themselves too seriously a guy gets
transferred into a different world but
it's a full-on comedy
I think
oh
um
okay now um speaking of things that
maybe you don't don't take themselves
too seriously have you read uh welcome
to demon School
no I think so yeah I don't know I don't
know if they translated that too
I think I know what you're talking about
it's a kid who was like adopted by
what's that called uh welcome to demon
school that's the title in English God
damn yeah yeah something like that it's
like there's this kid that was whatever
his name is he's like 14 years old his
parents sell him to some demons for
their own selfish reasons and then uh
because they need to travel and find
treasure that's what they want to do I
don't care or something like that right
but like it sends him to demon school
and he's a human he has like and so and
the humans are and like the demons hate
humans and he's like having to be keep
super on the down low and I know he's a
human they don't know but they can't see
like his pointy like Devil tail or
whatever no because some some demons
don't have that so so it's like oh it's
weird you're a weird looking demon
and they put in like a like a spell on
him so he doesn't smell human and [ __ ]
like that yeah oh it is really good why
does he why does he need to go to demon
School uh because his parents sold him
to like a demon Grandpa who always
wanted a demon a grandson
that face I know it sounds a little bit
like so do you but the demon Grandpa
also runs a like a principle of this
high school so it's like I can send him
to my school baby you'll see there's the
the grandpa know that he's a human yeah
or yeah I just wanted a grandson doesn't
give a [ __ ] ah okay fair yeah
in a way it's wholesome but also not
because literally it's talking about
selling their kid to uh some demons the
pink part is messed up but the wholesome
part is the grandpa is really nice and
everything what's there the animation
let's just like what like made in Abyss
type [ __ ] or like no no it's like it's
probably like low effort anime not
trying a lot of crazy [ __ ] I know
um okay what would be most similar to in
terms of what we've done no probably we
haven't really done anything that's like
purely comedy because even if we did
like one punch man when we did right one
punch man's already like crazy good
animation oh that was so much fun to
[ __ ] do
so kind I don't know it's a stretch to
maybe it's
maybe similar to promise Neverland like
it's it's more more
cartoony yeah yeah okay in terms of the
animation style but it's really really
good because I remember reading it and I
was like oh you really get invested in
it like quite a lot very at the very end
you got all these different factions and
players like trying to take over like
the school or and get into the human
world and the kid eventually gains the
ability to have access to powers and
he's able to like fight back and there's
this one story arc where there's this
big Festival going on and this character
set these Bombs all over this festival
and it's gonna kill a lot of people and
he has to figure out where the bombs are
how to turn them off so and he's like
enlists his friends but this character
is like a psychopath like he's really a
nuts type of villain and
it was just really really good so that
would that could be a good one for you
to read too but it's
it is long so might lose you there
uh there's an anime out there too in
which a man sells his son his son's body
part to demons and they then the sun
gets revenge what the [ __ ] I know
exactly what that is I know exactly what
the [ __ ] is you gotta tell me the time I
guess I can't remember there's too many
animals uh I think I wrote it down I
wrote it down what's the best animation
on the mangas we've done dumb the best
like art style or animation or in the
manga the anime that we've done oh
uh if you say a gin I will strangily
I don't like a joke
it's solid it's so high okay
what is it is it dorodoro
adorable
why have I heard someone say that before
it's on Netflix oh
it's really good let me read the
description I actually had this oh my
notes oh I'm so proud of you amazing
stream guys it's midnight all right bye
saying thank you for coming
have a good night bro
yeah so it is the story The Tragic birth
of kyaki kimaru in which his father
treats his Limbs and facial features to
Demons in exchange for wealth A Healer
named jukai finds the infant floating
alone on the river and takes him in he
gives him magical Prosthetics to form a
face and a body as well as a blade
capable of killing demons
we should do this
this would be super good was an anime
send it over yeah
write it down Violet ever again a father
for gardening I hear it's really good uh
it's really fun it's a kind of wholesome
right if I remember correctly
uh
uh simpleton who needs money you know
what you're right get [ __ ] saying
[Laughter]
oh
God
nice you and me yeah so good I remember
watching this and it's just super
compelling and the animation's good it's
pretty dark pretty gory so I think you'd
like it for sure and he he can't speak
right Andy I'm pretty sure he can't like
uh
the the sun when he grows up and he has
all these prosthetic limbs like he can't
talk
oh shivangi hey hey hey how's it going
good to have you again yeah yeah
we're just talking about uh what's our
favorite like animation type of anime
how about you Don you've like out of all
the the ones you've seen which one have
have you liked it
well okay I'm more of like a it's got to
be realistic as possible or cute which
is why I like a gin because it doesn't
look I mean it looks kind of strange but
like it looks kind of like I'm watching
a movie I'm a movie guy right or
something like um super cute like uh
made in Abyss
uh yeah like main demands it's cute I
like I like seeing all the [ __ ]
colors and all that [ __ ] unless it's
a zombie thing like High School of the
Dead now that thing was sick but that
was just because of the zombie I'm a
sucker
movie guy I love Island Man
uh what about y'all favorite art style
type thing
the worst one honestly even though the
story was good devil man cry baby it was
pretty strange the story was good but it
was very strange to me it's the same
style of like I think they wrapped it up
for Devilman crybaby but it's the same
style as Japan's thanks very much
correctly right yes the same art style
oh yeah it was very similar yeah yeah
that's true
the way they ran was so freaking weird
in Devilman crappy like all the way
yeah I mean oh yeah it was so strange oh
but a good story good story
I know what happened that should be the
next Naruto run
uh running into Area 51 swim running by
development oh that would be so funny
what about you Bobcat favorite animation
anime animation yeah uh I really like
art style I guess I don't know
yeah that's pretty good solid
uh but art style I really like uh most
of the art style from
your name the guy the guy who made your
name is really pretty
the movies we're talking about our anime
because I know what we I know other
animes out there stuff
yeah okay your name is pretty good but
out of the ones we did
yeah yeah it's not gonna be a chain
why what do you like that
I said one question
oh yeah okay yeah okay that's fair uh
you guys uh guys you never watch Sao FYI
like makiro
she called up
really good
uh have you seen World trigger damn
world trigger is such an old one
it will trigger like took a break
uh in the month for like a year or two
we got something for you Al shivangi oh
Bobcat when you suggested blood on
tracks manga I read the whole manga
through a pdf online in a day and I
cried at the end I don't know why but it
was so good my emotions was a roller
coaster oh contract is so good
hey there you go that sounds like uh the
kabaneri anime is that like same same
plotline vampires on the train yeah
let me look it up because I can't
remember the name of the
manga
animes that we've done my favorite art
style
favorite
that's tough
I think that
I liked
actually kind of like summertime
rendering all right that one's good
they're like yeah
like that was really clean the eyes are
super expressive like very expressive I
like that quite a lot
um I like uh it was very clean even when
they're like fast moving shots
everything was really crisp I liked that
quite a bit
um
have you you've never seen Jujutsu
Kaizen have you done you ever seen that
nope but I've heard you guys mention it
like 20 billion you should that's a
pretty good action uh kind of anime it's
got demons and like kind of like this
society that fights them and whatnot
and with these curses that they acquire
you go acquire a curse then you can
fight a demon and whatnot
and there's this character named it was
a Gojo or going to something or is yeah
out there currently
oh for sure his eye just type up go Joe
Jujutsu kaizen's eyeball you're like
you'll see it and he's like he's got
this like crazy colorful Vivid eyeball
and like all the women are like
you know uh when he did the reveal for
his face bro everyone [ __ ] died like
he's like a pretty young boy
oh yeah
uh
what's his name what am I typing in
so JoJo Kaizen yep yep look at chat yeah
uh mapa did go for aot yeah
they did food they did good food
you mean six eyes wait have I mean I
don't know
hmm
doing next
how you doing bro
hey Howdy Doody America attack
it looks like the glistening crystal is
not gonna lie
oh they're doing the chainsaw man
they're gonna do Finland Saga season two
crazy
yeah season one but uh Vikings yeah the
Viking one oh yeah you know about it
it's probably on Netflix eh
I mean I'm just a weeb king I don't know
is that uh what is Naruto
Ultimate Ninja hero oh yeah you know
what I that was my bad for picking
Naruto because you played the game
wait hold up is Finland Saga most
important question 12 episodes you shut
your mouth was 24. oh my God all right
you're gonna do it anyway
yeah I know you're gonna do it anyways
it's not like oh you can stop me baby
check
let's see picked up one punch man I
heard we're gonna do season three
that could be cool
that'd be sweet what
so you know one punch man that a other
Studio was doing the animation all that
stuff now mapa picked up one punch man
so thank you so because the first season
was amazing right like you've seen it
the animation's so good everyone's clean
the hits are like hits are powerful
everything's all good and then second
season they gave it to someone else they
gave it to like a
like a studio but not the greatest
Studio like animation stuff and then
everything felt like planned the
fighting felt like a bit like the old
school anime where everything's like it
was like like that it's not like crazy
good choreography
and then people were pissed
yeah shinjin comma well gonna go need to
finish the chapter deadline you go do
that
good luck with that deadline bro
just talk [ __ ] about
let's do it talking about what's his
face uh leaving and then now he's
leaving
weak right that's true oh that's right
no stamina or something right no sleep
yeah oh remember Alan we were talking
about how like KFC and you know whatever
it was Popeyes or something else
Popeye's better than chicken yeah
Chick-fil-A right yeah I remember that
[ __ ] other store never opens on
Sundays yeah that one so and you
remember when you said KFC sucks oh yeah
KFC socks okay
weebs they're coming out with burgers
and they have one that is called an
otaku Burger
okay oh you should try it
gotta try so bad but I can't you guess
where it is just guess where they sent
it no Spain that's [ __ ] Spain why
would you do that
because they got a console Spain because
they just [ __ ] got murdered by
Morocco in the World Cup oh did they
really I didn't see that God damn they
got they went into penalties and they
lost them they lost so bad not bad I
would not have seen that coming I
thought Spain would really good
yeah I gotta catch a game live bro I got
like two more weeks left right
I think it's probably a week left all
right get out again
hello no can anyone hear me
I can hear you you can hear me girl
I can hear you but now on my end from
looking at YouTube that has now start to
lag and then it's kicked back in so
that's going on
I do not know find weebs
everything's all good
whoo that was a scare what was I talking
about oh that's right the wonder that is
the otaku burger oh yeah that's true
that's right
so they were talking about how it's like
the a sweetness of like the sauce with a
salty Savory Burger where they added
like Teriyaki coated fried uh stuff and
it just sounded Divine and I was like I
want it they got that secret Uhn flavor
you did so good
yeah it was pain then I started talking
[ __ ] about Spain they [ __ ] cut my
internet right I know that's where they
took you down quarterfinals are starting
for tomorrow for the Springfield yeah
you're right yeah I need to catch game
bro that's right we're back very good
thank you so glad to be back I know I
just thought that looked amazing
so
somebody
record yourself eating it when you get
the when you go to Spain but yeah yeah
ask a Spanish friend to record himself
no you know what we can do Griffin you
know what we can do for uh one of our
episodes for this one once we finish
talking about anime you better [ __ ]
buy Chick-fil-A KFC Popeyes blindfold
yourself pick out what the best one is
absolutely I'm gonna I'm doing it I'm
writing this down this is happening
should we do that net week next week or
something do you think you can do it
next week are we just gonna watch
Griffin we eat food wait
um well what do you guys got over there
we could like I don't know no no I think
if you do it well I'll get like snacks
but you know
uh someone's gonna help you out uh well
it's like it's gonna be late it's like
11 p.m I'm not gonna eat at 11 p.m
I mean I can't I don't give a [ __ ] but
like what would I eat
so Chick-fil-A Burger King
Burger King
Chick-fil-A Burger King what's another
one are we talking about like chicken
sandwiches right we're just watching you
eat I thought that was a purpose
there's no purpose
if uh until Griffin says that my
Popeye's Burger is better than his
Chick-fil-A
you know
but it has to be a blindfold test and
someone has to give it to him somehow
I think I can figure out a way okay I
will figure out a way yeah go figure out
if we can do it next week great if we
can't we'll do it some other time we
will just set it up somehow all right
but I'll be sick though keep it in the
the back burner
the after show we're trained to Griffin
ASMR Channel I don't know if that's
gonna sound really ASMR if I'm chewing
I'm going
that that's not very let me get on this
oh guys weeps you don't understand
whenever Dom gets super excited about
something he'll do that he'll go
why don't you do that
you make this weird ass
Bobcat all right videos of Dom being
super drunk
oh [ __ ] no I can't show that
yes
I can ask I can ask our good friend uh
who has a lot of videos on me and Dom
and Hope
see be right back legendary I see you
that week yo so someone asked earlier do
you play video games I don't do that so
Much Anymore Alan Dom they do dog
doesn't play video games all right yeah
I played out last like a couple weeks
back come on no from one you know I'm
pretty
I'm like
in a joke
joke seriously also [ __ ] look what you
guys did oh what'd I do all right Dom
and I and a other friend made a YouTube
channel a while ago uh not just for fun
not trying to do anything crazy Dom has
not been on the YouTube channel or been
on Twitch streaming with us for the last
okay okay okay I know how it's done here
I know how it sounds
pretty bad okay let me defend myself let
me defend that now don't interject let
me defend myself and then we'll reach a
resolution so you know what 15 seconds
go okay so initially I joined because we
were supposed to do a gaming podcast
with like edited videos right so that
was fun but it is a lot of work and I
can't edit for [ __ ] so we've not had
that much time to edit videos so that's
why we turn to streaming I don't like
streaming I don't care what people watch
it but I gotta get back into it soon
okay uh I'm gonna get back into it soon
Outlast part two I'll get into it next
week's Bobcat just mentioned uh because
Bob haven't mentioned it it was freaking
awesome
I haven't had time to finish it I have
had so much stuff going around me so I
wasn't able to
finish it so if you put any spoilers I
know you gave us five [ __ ] bucks I
will destroy you theology
[Laughter]
good
I'm fine you oh no shivangi oh no I'm so
sorry she said she just cracked up
laughing due to uh to us and her brother
was asleep next to her or um
nice of course oh that is hilarious oh
my gosh oh anyways I brought that up
video games not for Dom to get
restorated bye
at least showing up to it good yeah have
you guys have you guys played The Last
of Us right
have you seen the new trailer have you
seen the new trailer
hasn't come out yet right uh it's coming
on next march I believe okay
all right see okay Theo very nice now
man I wouldn't do that to you very kind
anyways so the HBO is going to be doing
like a live action of The Last of Us
so I'm really excited about that and
guess what they they're adding the voice
actor Troy Baker the guy who does Joel
yeah yeah they got Troy Baker and Ashley
Johnson
uh it's two Game of Thrones actors it's
Bella Ramsay uh and what's what's his
name he uh Edgar no no
no I forgot his he's like in Cuban or
something or like no he's texting
yeah but his family is Mexican or
something no it was like Texan I can't
remember if it's I don't remember
originally I can look it up
uh now he's on the come up though I like
that actor just forgot his name
wait who are you talking about the same
guy who did uh who's playing Joel In The
Last of Us
oh no no did he also played the bounty
hunter in the Pedro Pascal Pedro pascals
or he's like is he like Argentinian or
some something ah thank you Mac look
back attack thank you yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I love that dude
that was good but like Troy Baker oh
he's so good like his voice actor have
y'all played like when he was the Joker
yeah I've seen interviews with him and
[ __ ] like he's pretty good oh so I love
that the Joker voice is like well Batman
like I just uh great voice I love that
guy but honestly I love uh I love Troy
Baker he's so good and The Last of Us
and and other [ __ ] that he's in he's
never gonna beat out uh Mark Hamill and
Joker
oh well I mean he didn't try to I was I
was watching background videos because
like when I was working on you know my
own yoga voice that I got now
like I was like looking at Mark Hamill I
was looking at Troy Baker's and in one
of the interviews Troy was like man I
got like so into my own head like I
because I was so intimidated because
like Mark had either just done
a big game or show as doing the voice so
when it was like his turn to do it he
was like oh my gosh super overwhelmed
and he got nervous
and like that he was talking about his
director and how she was like really
helping him saying like listen
Mark's voice is like it's like a refined
sword or like a laser it's like very
refined he's got it down to a science
you you're like a fire hose or like a
flamethrower
you know and like so just embrace you
basically you do you
and kind of form your own version of it
and like for some reason that clicked
with him and he was able to create that
voice for the Joker nice all right Baker
um Troy Baker
uh can you can I suggest my fave ghost
animation Channel he doesn't he don't
make any videos anymore but his previous
ones are dope
uh
what go fave ghost animation Channel I
don't know maybe it's like yeah sure
and [ __ ] hit mishawangi
yeah
you look good what else you're [ __ ]
weebs energy
okay all right
and that that that's all I got I got
another
we got nothing
why did you bring up me reading manga
and falling off
that was actually [ __ ] good now guys
seriously he was reading uh he was
reading a manga and then he fell down
and he like flat on his face and then
the manga was so good he literally got
back up and just continued reading not
so much of a weeb he is
all right the manga wasn't good I
was just trying to read it
oh so cute
do you guess the Bridge series my
favorite is dbza I never understood
anime a bridge what is it about
Griffin you're right no don't know
nothing I don't know what is it I also
don't know nothing
what is anime a bridge because I people
gotta explain have you guys ever read
any Gigi Ito Works my favorite one is
Enigma of amigara fault yes that is the
best one that is my favorite one okay 15
seconds give us the description I've
given you the description box give it
again I forgot 15 seconds here we go
me uh yes you go someone found uh oh my
God my brain
uh that was a discovery you know in the
mountain there's like human-shaped holes
and then people started to be interested
in the human shape holes because
apparently some people start so
intrigued that like they felt that that
holes belonged to them in a way that uh
it intrigued them so they start going
into the holes and then they realized at
the end of the whole at the end of the
site at other side of the hole it's all
messed up and they [ __ ] and they're
[ __ ] okay
okay okay oh that is the one yes yeah
yeah yeah
thank you
Fila Theo is that where they did the
full freezer Series in 16 episodes
uh guys Marvel or DC what do you like
Griffin go
Marvel
Dom go
uh well I would say Marvel generally but
I'm kind of bored as [ __ ] of them right
now but that's a whole other story yeah
there why are you bored with them I
don't know to be honest like after the
whole end game thing I'm like oh yeah
I've like I've grown up with it now I'm
good for like 10 years maybe I'll come
back you know like I'm good for a while
like let me look at some other [ __ ]
let me look at DC I don't know let's do
some [ __ ] I don't know if they're not
getting lost 100 million bucks
which one Black Adam show
that Black Adam movie oh yeah I did yeah
I heard it was and The Rock was super
salty
he was promoting the shine out of that I
saw him yeah he was trying so hard
when IGN says like Oh Black Panther 2
got a lot of uh money from like their
opening weekend and Black Adam got this
amount of money he was like over and he
was super salty on Twitter
in its first movie also made like a like
a billion dollars or something nice yeah
because I saw I saw Dwayne and IG was
like oh thank you guys opening this and
I'm like but I heard it with [ __ ] though
like why are you hype but now it makes
sense
uh see hey mag attack feels you says
honestly get the Marvel fatigue feel
like they should take some rest yeah
honestly honestly honestly just take a
break
no no I mean like because there's like
isn't there like six this year six or
seven movies movies plus series
uh uh they're Spider-Man
homecoming early this year black panther
too
uh eternals
uh about that movie uh and then there's
like like their She-Hulk the show
there's Loki there's like there's so
much Loki's really good uh she-hawk is
really okay
it's fine it's fine it's a comedy show
but it was like they try to build it
into something else didn't really work
um missio Ronaldo guys uh Messi all the
way
guy
I'm not a
football uh Messi and Ronaldo is like
the big Superstars uh oh you don't know
who Messi is Griff
oh what I knew what was it Lionel Messi
Lionel yeah Lionel Messi yeah yeah he's
kind of like wizard with football and I
know Ronaldo he's like oh yeah he's
pretty good too you know yeah yeah wait
didn't Ronaldo do some sort of thing
where he dressed up as an old man in
like Italy or Venice and he was kicking
around a soccer ball and it's like kids
and stuff to see if they would like play
a game with him or whatever and then
like eventually he tore off his mask and
everyone's like oh my gosh oh there was
a whole thing on YouTube about it Mike
and he's a Ronaldo fan all right we
don't want Ronaldo fans here all right
get the [ __ ] up
I really don't care about football I
just like watching the World Cup
yeah I can get I can get into the games
though a couple of pints with the lads
and [ __ ] fun [ __ ] that's right when I
was um when I was still living in my
parents house uh we they had a foreign
exchange to it in one year I think it
was
or something like that
um he he was with us and he loves soccer
too he also got really big into the
Dodgers the Los Angeles Dodgers he was
up at like midnight watching the game on
his phone anyways he was like hardcore
into the into that so there's that sad
that sounds uh what is he Korean Chinese
yep Korea Korean because that really has
a really big uh baseball thing yeah it's
true they do uh Korean Japan has a
really big baseball thing if you like
have you seen any like Japanese anime
there's a lot of things like there's a
lot of baseball [ __ ] uh apparently uh
baseball's really big in the in high
school
uh in the high school thing and then
apparently I don't know right right
isn't there one that's like one pitch or
something not uh it's like things like a
anime weebs let me know if I'm getting
this right ace of diamonds I think
that's like the biggest one
okay I think I don't know what one pitch
but
it involves like gambling and how like
you only get either like one maybe two
pitches or whatever and it just like I
don't think that if you missed a certain
it's probably not it it's probably not
it but that's probably not it
ah
but anyways yeah okay
well someone's got a question for orange
guy I'm guessing that's you Griff
orange guy
best name best name
[Music]
yeah oh it is the shirt too and it's
like [ __ ]
anyway what's the question do I look
orange I guess maybe a little bit what's
your favorite anime oh favorite anime is
I've talked about it for but I would
have to say first it's
are we back
uh refreshed
can anyone hear me testing one two three
I think we're back yeah we're back we're
back
everyone I'm sorry
yeah that's right throw some crap on him
everyone I didn't really want to talk
about anime anymore that's why it seemed
tight
that's right
let's see
uh has anyone seen blue lock yet
no yes we are back whoa oh good we're
back uh blue lock is a good like uh it's
also a football thing
yeah it's a football thing but you'll
enjoy it it's very Action Sports kind of
I uh feeling oh where uh because they
made it into like a death game kind of
not really death game but you if you
want to be if you want to be the best
Striker you have to beat out all the
other Strikers that's basically it if
you don't there's no Keepers there's no
goalkeepers there's no defense nothing
they picked every Str like the best
strikers in every like high school and
they compete to be the best one to
represent Japan that's basically oh nice
okay
all right so I mean I did wait Al you
don't like I shield 21 right I Love
Actually 21 I don't like that you do
okay great I don't love the anime I love
the manga manga is so [ __ ] sick Bro
have you watched spare me great Lord I'm
gonna look that up real quick because I
might have fear me great
look it's uh the screen for it he went
to who knows where all right let's see
Lord
have I seen this
I am thinking no unfortunately I have
not I am sorry nope I have not seen that
one
Dom is back yes he is finally what is
your favorite freaking anime I was
saying what was it berserk and um
followed by Samurai seven and then it
was
um heroic age those are my three
favorite oh and uh gurin Logan lagon
those are that's the other one I like a
lot
good and lagging and Dom no clipped to
the back room
uh very good
uh Dom doesn't know anything about memes
so I know all the memes what is
background oh it's
that no the back room or the thing
yo theological introspection has got a
one-piece tattoo
what is it is on your hand or something
or like what are we talking
Dom's gonna get a tattoo of this video
uh thumbnail on his face okay I'm not I
don't know about the Geo thumbnail but
like Geo something okay calm down he
wants to get the Geo thumbnail the Hulk
that would be hella weird bro
oh you don't want he doesn't want it to
be on his face Griff he wants to be a
full back tattoo that's what he wants
back spread ouch I would take a back
like a full back tattoo rather than
having anything on my face I would
definitely like if I don't really like
that face anyway
couchers
legendary bro I know Karen Lagan is so
good yes it is really good but it's
certainly it starts small in terms of
like the universe but by the end of it
they're like fighting in like the outer
space and third Dimensions it gets crazy
do you remember that one now girl lion
yeah
I haven't seen it you haven't seen it
wow yeah I haven't seen a lot of like
because a lot of old school anime I
don't think there's a lot of there was a
manga that that was attached to it
that's why I haven't seen Code Geass
haven't seen uh girl Lagan
I think and then I've only seen like the
one I've only read the ones that had
mangas attached to it
have you watched one piece I have
watched some one piece I've read up one
piece a lot more
is anyone watching parallel world
Pharmacy I don't know what the story is
for that anime
parallel parallel world Pharmacy I think
it's an isekai where the guy was a
doctor or was a pharmacist or was it
yeah
uh drug Creator like a pharmaceutical
drug guy and then he got isekai and then
he became like oh this world [ __ ]
sucks they only have magic and they're
really bad with their uh hospitals and
[ __ ] so I better make
because they keep using healing magic
and they have to get someone with
healing magic to fix someone else I
think if that that's what the thing is
so he made he actually made drugs for
like a cold she like
and other stuff okay I think so
FMA Brotherhood [ __ ] sick
Luffy's flag on his shoulder cool
very nice
waiting
yeah a flag of One Piece oh yeah totally
Tom black you know what it is he was he
was playing for like 15 minutes
while we were talking about anime he
doesn't even know what we talked about
previously hey come on this
laughs
okay
what was it um do you know
into a vending machine sexy Dio Brando
it's like anime
reincarnate into a vending machine that
probably was a short series please tell
me it doesn't have like 50. it's on
snowboard I've never seen it but I heard
it a lot I don't know if it's good I
need this okay nuts
yunji into manga is better than yeah I
mean totally I think most manga is
better than the than the anime for sure
jujito is the best
uh because Gigi Ito the great thing
about junji Ito yes his art style is
really good on like uh mangoes right
compared to uh and we mastered the a
thing called the page turned um where
you read a manga and every time when you
turn a page like [ __ ] scary like
you're anticipating like a scary thing
and like the turn of a page
that's what's made jujito super good
because every your you get scared for
turning a page because it's super scary
interesting I gotta check out this
page Turner
you're really you're gonna check it out
it's the scary thing I'll check it out
I'll look at a page here's one Dom why
don't you go find one of Junior ito's
things and you could actually try to
read just a few pages of it say next
week I can have my KFC my burgers and
sandwiches and
we're doing a book club this sounds like
that goodreads.com type where like the
teacher asked okay read the next chapter
by next week kids so this is what if
that sounds but it's manga
that's true and I am the weave King so
like yeah maybe I got a few show up yeah
be a king and listen to your subject all
right I'll talk with the higher-ups
coming up resolution about that
okay
it's got 110 chapters
that's a negative for me
oh my gosh what has uh
you gotta go Mac attack week what's the
next how to be better see you next time
how to beat
I don't know man uh I actually some
sometimes I genuinely forget what video
is coming out because I'm so ahead of
scripts I'm like Bobcat what the [ __ ]
are we releasing he's like dog but yeah
I actually I forgot what where
I don't now remember
one piece really shut the [ __ ] up my
stuff I think so
someone's been shouting one piece
legendary
everywhere
I'm just taking out taking it out on
Macedon
I apologize gotta go for a while bye
legendary uh at this point ain't even
scared of any other horror animation
because his stories are already so scary
uh creeps me out jujitos Chris creepy
bro
isn't he really nice dude though he's
super nice dude
it's always the nicest guys with the
craziest imagination all right oh yeah
so that means
Al's terrifying
am I nice am I a nice guy that's true
kind of feisty
her phone did the guy on the right go to
a wedding after all he's in costume and
everything you don't understand this
ain't a costume this this Dom the weeb
king his natural state of being
I wake up and I'm just like suited up
always he always is no now it's a
special occasion anime uh podcast with
the boys every week suited and booted
baby
part of a thing
all right but yeah that's funny
right Dom that's true
yes
oh one day when I when I visit him I'll
take a picture of what he naturally
looks like and I posted it on our
Instagram
that's dangerous bro that's danger do I
have an old photo of Dom I'm gonna look
it up oh please dude okay if you
actually have a like old photo you can
show it on camera right now I'll allow
that one okay but to catch around the
wild I don't know that's scary that's
like
you sent me a lot of photos back in the
day
you know I noticed I was watching
parasite you only use the one photo bro
I sent you so much because uh that was
the funniest one
Dom just likes looking Schmick
don't know what that word is but I like
it is
I'm hoping it's good
I'll take it
Mick Urban Dictionary oh
shmake
oh it's the most embarrassing one is
this wife make sure I'm making sure I'm
spelling this right
s-h-m-i-c-k Urban Dictionary a person
usually of low intelligence who wears
sportswear and acts in a threatening
manner damn [ __ ] being called out huh
Schmick
Fair
I'm gonna show Dom's fuckboy era
that's [ __ ] all right whatever show
it show it here we go where is it let's
have a look
oh my God look at this [ __ ] boy dude
it was for a joke it was for a joke back
in the Snapchat days I don't you anymore
but back in the you know that era was
Savage if it was a joke what is their
second one
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know respected
you are I don't know about respect that
Theo says he's sorry geez my bad I meant
slick he meant slick oh okay okay so
we're running a whole tangent yeah Ah
that's
show me like a sneak peek first let me
just judge it
oh yeah okay that was that was a long
time ago that was a long time ago Jesus
uh look at that look at that boy
oh that's funny yeah it was like that
was like seven years ago bro chill out
God damn it seven years ago
I think six maybe yeah
maybe five anyways back to anime or
whatever with the [ __ ] we're talking
about we all have official insta
artificial instead it's dead
what's up we used it for a while but we
never used it again honestly we need to
get back to it it's just like it's hard
to manage a lot of [ __ ] at the same time
but like we need to I don't know
but you can always call our official
Instagrams our our
personal ones
find it there you go
you can find it in our description I
think
yes in our descriptions is the links to
our uh Instagram I think we have a tick
tock
we're still busy
I'm sorry that has to be in your head
but also not sorry that's not down
that's Tom
I don't like that one
what else weebs
photo what a tangent what a tangent
that was a doozy of a tangent did we
watch bakkie I have it looks very good
oh it's a shite though it's a lot of a
lot of fighting a lot of good
what a good Fighting fight fight fight
fight but all the dudes are like super
jacked so you'll probably be into that
like crazy jacks
[Laughter]
my stupid brain bro
all right
but Dom would probably be super into
what's a super cute one honestly he'd
probably be super into kind of spikes
family it's a super cute anime
uh yeah okay is that a that's not really
a how to beat this just more of a no
it's just enjoyable to watch uh okay
fair probably
Shojo uh like magical girl side or magic
one of the magical girl one you'll
probably enjoy too
okay because it's cute and it's [ __ ]
up
uh I like that The Perfect combo well I
was watching made in Abyss the first one
when uh Rico's hand literally got like
flesh torn out I was like what the [ __ ]
am I thought this is a cute [ __ ]
anime because I like that the contrast
the cute and the the net because
everyone's everyone every time I talk
about made in Abyss to everyone who's
seen it saying oh that one episode like
what the [ __ ] happened in that one
episode I thought I was like oh they
probably really just got messed up or
something oh yeah yeah
you remember what was it um the the
movie they did it's kind of like not
really in episode two not like made in a
bit season two was like what was it dawn
of the or something
I can't remember it's when Bond rude
Captain you saw pruska getting all like
oh I was [ __ ] big bro yeah
yeah yeah that was rough too yeah that
was a hardcore one oh Al have you seen
elf in lead I saw a common in this
earlier but I didn't I saw a manga I saw
I read the Manga like years years ago I
can't remember anything I think it might
be a good anime to do I remember it
being super messed up
um
you guys been waiting for it to be
released guess the guy in the middle is
waiting for a spicy one
for it's got the face got the face
hell yeah he's got the face
what the [ __ ] that's gonna be a thing
I'm gonna fire you the [ __ ] out
oh Andy is it like the not demon
Overlord it's like wizard Overlord but
isn't he like some kind of wizard dude
who's like stupid power
but it's great the MC's just too
overpowered but he wears an amulet to
suppress his powers isn't that every
[ __ ] anime
that is a lot of them that's for sure uh
well one punch man make here make made a
new manga yeah I heard but if it's has
it started
I don't know if it's what is that I
don't know what that is he's making a
new manga with a new artist
because he finished the last one so uh
I'm gonna look it up you guys chat
okay
talk [ __ ] oh someone's brought up uh you
got something no no I was gonna ask
what's his favorite what is his what are
you guys TV shows that you guys been
waiting for because someone the guy
asked oh right
um oh you're right I'm waiting on uh I
want to see Witcher I want the next
Witcher to come out
um looking up looking forward to
stranger things the last season of
stranger things I'm looking forward to
that
and um
that's kind of the two that I'm waiting
on what about you I hear Wednesday's
good
people have been talking about Wednesday
oh yeah they're the chick from that
she's in a u
H yeah
good uh good actor
uh apparently that's really good and
it's like one of the best Netflix shows
in the first week it beat out Wednesday
or whatever Wednesday yeah
first week is like beat out stranger
things it's like one of the better
showing off Netflix it was crazy I don't
know if that meant if the show is really
good or just people a lot of people
watched it I'm assuming it's because a
lot of people watched it
yeah I would hope that it would be
something good yeah someone else had
brought up again chainsaw man so it
actually I pulled it up the description
of it because you said you saw first few
minutes of it was it like episode one
Dom or anything no I saw the spikes
family like the first few minutes oh
Spike's family so here's something maybe
this will get you you can start the
clock great great actor what do you
saying so chainsaw man plot summary says
denji a destitute young man who lives in
a world with bloodthirsty monsters
called Devils one day he befriends
pochita who is a devil dog thing but
also a literal chainsaw and if that
wasn't weird things take a real turn
when denji is murdered by gangsters and
pochita fuses with his soul to save his
life this perpetually hungry and horny
denji turns into chainsaw man who ends
up hurting other Devils for the
enigmatic woman named makima a woman who
works for a governmental Bureau of devil
hunters and strings denji along with the
vague promises of sex and Fortune and
she treats them a little more than dog
himself it's literally the mark makima
That's what her name is I can't remember
her name I was actually interesting yeah
literally said it was like if you work
for me maybe I'll let you touch my boob
and then he's like [ __ ] you hey never
let him touch it never dude got nothing
bro that's like the way to make every
like 14 year old like do free labor
forever
the smartest way
this and also a quick way to jail
uh Wednesday Adams was fire I'll
recommend it oh nice what about Ragnarok
uh you mean God of War Ragnarok or
Ragnarok the the anime something I can
Valkyrie
uh record of Ragnarok
apparently that's really good
rent a girlfriend anime made me so
single even though I'm a girl I am
jealous the main character boy what's
wrong with your girlfriend uh retro
girlfriend is super waifu uh girl uh
anime show it's about a guy who's who
got broken up by his girlfriend uh
broken up because some stupid reason
because [ __ ] kids you know and then
the guy felt so bad they had to he had
to go home for something so he felt so
guilty for not being bringing his
girlfriend so he rented a girlfriend
because you know there's a culture in
Japan where you can rent uh people
people's time yeah
for not crazy sexual [ __ ] but just like
yeah Sony like rented cuddlers and [ __ ]
you can rent like a girlfriend you can
rent a mom a parent
literally you can rent anything a sister
if you want to
because apparently yeah uh uh but uh and
then he finds out that this and then he
met a girl the girls like super perfect
and [ __ ] falls in love with a girlfriend
this like rented girlfriend and I was
like oh [ __ ] date ends whatever he
goes back to school realizes that the
girl also attends his school and the
shenanigans happen and then they never
still to this day still ongoing
love-hate relationship it's kind of
[ __ ] I need to [ __ ] rent a mom
for like an anime video at some point
I'm like we get that would not that'd be
a cool like uh clickbait title and like
you know whatever like that'll be here
and I'm the guy with the [ __ ] face
you pieces
yes because I'm wearing the suit bro I
deflect all you know
yeah
right you you need to rent a mom for an
anime I'm saying it'll be a good video
because like rent a mom like what's
going on puts on your camera videos like
yeah it's a more video it's a random
video
[Laughter]
yo uh someone is saying um orange guy
what is the next how to beat video
he's trying to get he's gonna [ __ ]
info
I can't give a hint great name I don't
even know how you'd give a hint though
like what would the hint be the most
General generic hint I can give him yeah
a sword is involved
that's pretty good that's about it
yeah that's pretty good
yeah
your guys videos are great I don't even
watch the anime but I watch all your
videos
appreciate it
I just gotta text my friend and his
Crush confessed to her looks like my
luck going down oh you lonely [ __ ] it's
all right I'm here with you too
I'm here with you too baby I'm also
lonely as [ __ ] damn shivangi
one day or you will you will meet
somebody one day we'll all we'll oh no
Griff's already one day we'll all
find our person
I'm good yeah I found my person
for sure
it's not just cute it's one of the one
which made me feel single
uh Vicky Moore was that another also
it's the newest the newest waifu
Material Girl also
it's pretty big she's pretty good uh the
mug is pretty fun to watch is but
uh this conversating this guy
but the guy's more like a meat guy so
the girl's way cooler than him but she's
cool and like a manly masculine way and
the guy's like super into it and
everyone's super into it
well we can do like how to beat the
waifu and whatever
yeah
for that
Al was there a manga or something where
it was about like this this chick who
was a knight and
um she had like a six-pack but like she
wore armor and there's this like really
like dweebie like lame dude who was like
totally into the chick and he was like
and she's like oh
there's like a it's like I'm a knight
you and I also have scars you people
don't like me it's like I like you and
then she got super flustered I was like
oh yeah
yeah yeah and then I can't remember the
title but it was a while ago I can't
remember either FBI opened up because
Don said he literally cut off it's like
how to beat a waifu it's like all right
if I can someone got to call out the
cops on it fair play fair play I'm just
a wave King hands up I'm just the weave
King don't do anything
I mostly watch Shonen an anime what do
you watch uh
Tanish what's your favorite one yes
let's see Robert your videos are great I
don't even watch anime but I've watched
all of your videos thank you very much
so I've heard that like 45 seconds ago I
felt like I had just had Deja wow
I don't know why when I was editing that
that [ __ ] phrase came up [ __ ] 10
times what it was like
uh Griffin saying I think I just have
Deja Vu he's like what
in the there's something you in the
video in parasite
either on parasite or what it was on
the one before the I can't remember what
the name is summertime rendering
I was like I think I just haven't Deja
Vu it's like I don't know why it's like
I've been it's stuck in my brain they're
just like
okay one piece of Naruto are my favorite
yep
for sure they're good they're long but
they're good
what else watching mob psycho now yeah
mob cycle is great
what's that um what's that one
um
Yakuza dude becomes like a husband or
something was it way about the way of
the house husband yeah
it's a comedy show it's fun okay
you need to stream more to get more
views
I don't know maybe
maybe we're trying that we're trying to
manage once a week for starters and see
like you know
for sure how we handle I mean what do
you guys want us to stream we're just
we're usually just talk about the the
last one we do it's like unless you guys
want us to stream other stuff you know
oh true
we've already got some ideas where
apparently I'll be trying a lot of
different uh fast food in the next few
weeks putting on the pounds makes sense
yeah he's two bucks right and I'm too
insecure about that that's fair there's
stuff that gobbler
open that mouth Griff yeah just keep
that [ __ ]
Italian chicken burger or dude I eat so
much food I'm hungry all the time
hello Genesis hello Genesis how we doing
anime manga all the way baby
oh streaming some games
well Bobcat would like that guy in a
wedding costume you know that you're
scared of [ __ ] out of you scared the
[ __ ] out of me once you know how to beat
anime video because I was watching the
video well focused
I should have leveled the audio a little
bit better I guess
oh sorry about that
what's better the steam deck or Nintendo
switch depends on which game you like do
you like Nintendo games
or do you like
other games other than Nintendo
all right
I'm a big Nintendo guy so it's like and
also I like playing on my PC so
maybe steam deck
you know and I I probably have access to
I think a Nintendo switch or something I
think I probably could so if we wanted
to do some sort of thing I thought the
stream deck was popping though it's
popping as [ __ ] but we can't get it
though it's only an American thing is it
really I don't know maybe if someone
[ __ ] did
Steve
send us a stuff you know
I'll review it for no reason on an anime
channel
do we have some moderators are you
volunteering do Brando uh we'll we'll do
a poll one of these days to find out
who's who can be the best moderator and
then we'll pick five all right and then
they have to beat themselves to the
death
not themselves they hate each other to
the death and then you have a Nick the
Victoria nickname
wedding costume I mean wedding costumes
we could call him The Wedding Crasher
hey great film great film I know it is a
good movie
watch me I'm watching many animes
because of our video nice thank you
uh Divine gay okay I got some nice
that's true that makes sense to also
it says all the time and for me really
get to know more about good anime
I mean we sometimes don't do a lot of
good enemies
yeah I'm working on one right now and
it's it's it's tough tough the fourth
episode
no the one before that the the weird one
the movie really weird the movie okay
yeah it's strange yeah me and uh we were
talking about me and Dom like it's it's
weird
very hard to follow that's about all I
can give you how to be
what's up is it good for how to beat
uh um which one the one you're the one
you said it's weird I mean yeah it's you
know you get some interesting [ __ ] the
visual stuff visuals can be pretty
intense
um certainly unique in terms of art
style I'm trying to be vague so you're
saying I have to censor a lot of things
uh
yes
yes all right that's fine
Arts guy wedding costume guy and bobcat
that's not orange anymore it's not
Orange
yeah but I like the name is cute
ah
no
do a mod
and then I'm dying first in the
moderator oh no that's it the guy on the
left is orange guy the one in the middle
of spicy
why am I spicy spice
someone in the comments said like you
were spicy because of your hair like you
have you have powers in your hair
apparently it's the Bobcat I'm gonna
grow it out y'all don't understand his
hair used to be really long and when we
were out in La he still had it pretty
long and I had a hug here all right
that's pretty well
I know he actually let me touch it there
it was magically soft
so that is the thing
the only reason why Dom has that rug on
his chair because he misses patting my
hair
the [ __ ] APA yeah
because I used to have really like what
a blonde hair right back in the day yeah
yeah
uh switch is seven years old yeah but
it's still a good game but it's really
apparently uh apparently I play I'm
playing it but Pokemon Scarlet is pretty
[ __ ] uh really running badly
[Music]
no I'm pretty um
pretty pretty Solo in my
Global exploits
right pretty pretty solo at the moment
yeah
the only one that's married or in a
relationship of some kind is [ __ ]
this guy this old married guy over here
that's right
the man from the 1960s and I remember
when the sky was blue and we all drove
we all look orange
[Laughter]
back in my day we all look orange
you're right
we all did spray tan it was wonderful
let's see Irish baritone is really bad
um spray Tan's not good regular tanning
actually does have health benefits a lot
of people give it a bad rap like it's
like less than one percent of people who
actually do
they can get like cancer but it's like
less than one percent and you have to
like basically expose yourself to it in
an extreme amount okay
so it's like someone's trying to hit on
Dom's dumb oh you're getting someone's
hitting on you weird questions
the Dio Brando is trying to hit undone
all right right are you going to make a
Discord server in the new feature
hopefully yeah I'm trying to make one uh
I wanna I'm trying to make one just so
uh with like good moderation good
everything's like setup so everyone
don't uh go crazy on it did you see
Alden ring got an update now it has PVP
Mode God
Siobhan you [ __ ] do it great
no
of course I might talk about it more
it's gonna be
orange guy um
It's called Skin Cancer
what else lads I think that's it
yeah
I think that's about it that's about it
can we got more dare you guys have any
stories you guys want to tell to uh take
us out of the Stream
no I got nothing
oh
nope I don't think I got anything
um
I can I can tell a a story about me
having really bad
uh
uh
what is it I bought something
for a lot of money
for a stupid reason because I really
want the collection
some like
okay like what that's uh I think it's
more of like not by not currently having
buyer remorse but I do have a
uh you can see in the background
that poster
it's a Harry Potter poster a big fan of
Harry Potter okay when I was young right
yeah boy
I I I I'm also a big fan of this guy
called Ollie Moss uh for he's a great
artist love him uh great art style he
does a lot of Artemis posters
and then I bought because I I wouldn't
have that much money he was selling it
for if you want to buy the whole thing
it's like 200 bucks right for the whole
line of like one to seven Harry Potter
so it's like [ __ ] it I'll just buy three
and seven because three is my favorite
movie Seven's the end and I really like
the seventh movie uh part one part two
oh those are good yeah the prisoner of
azkadam right yeah
you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
um and then now I want to buy the whole
[ __ ] series
and every [ __ ] because this guy only
is a famous kind of artist and uh only
did like a limited run for it uh it's on
there's only like 2 000 ish posters
outside each per poster
oh
looking at eBay
one poster is 300 bucks
these hmos is mad and I looked at eBay
the other day like two three weeks ago
and there's like if you want to buy a
whole series it's three thousand dollars
oh
yeah so damn bro I didn't I didn't buy
the three thousand dollars all that
money I didn't I didn't buy that one I
didn't buy that one all right no but uh
after this and then in my house like
[ __ ] it I'm not gonna buy the whole
series I'll probably collect one by one
every year I'll buy one more and one
more and then I'll finish my collection
that way and then suddenly on eBay while
I was looking around suddenly there is a
someone selling it on
as a bidding thing because if you know
eBay you can set up as like I just want
to sell it I want to put it a price
that's like thirty thousand dollars or
you can put it as a bid and it can go as
high as you can or you can go as low as
you if no one wants to buy it right so
uh
someone was selling it for 300 bucks
the whole series
the whole lot oh okay
[ __ ] it I'll get it right now and then
I'll and I put the bid in and then it
went up to 600 bucks it's like [ __ ] me
and then after that I was like [ __ ] it
I'll wait until the end of the thing uh
at the end of the line and we'll see if
I get it and I after that I put in a 750
bucks and I [ __ ] got it
750 bucks
oh wait how many posters or how much
seven posters
so seven pieces of paper seven pieces of
paper
art art right it's art the thing is if
I'm able to sell it all right if I'm
able to sell it uh two of the ones that
I don't need because I have three and
seven already right oh neonicon do you
have your watch please tell me you have
your watch
if I'm able to sell the two ones that I
don't don't have
uh uh how much money could you make on
those two posters probably 300 250 300
bucks each so I'll just probably be
using up 200 bucks if I'm able to get
back you can buy like a solid Seiko baby
alpiness with that solid
that's why I literally told my friend
because I've been sending it to uh
Griffin I'm sending it to
uh Calvin so help me out okay let me
sell it and so
because if you sell stuff from the
states people trust it a little bit more
than uh yeah that's why I was like can
you help me sell it you can have ten
percent if you can if you were able to
sell it more you can have whatever you
know it's like he said okay I was
selling it and after that I was like
yeah but that's
that's uh my biggest buy this year and I
wasted 800 bucks on a piece of paper but
if I get to sell it I I it's like
[ __ ] that's true that's fair
I got um I don't know let's see in terms
of waste probably not a waste but
um I mean I did overspend when we did
that the anime figurine challenge I kind
of cheated do you put it do you put it
uh do you put it somewhere that [ __ ]
Imperial drama
the Digimon
oh yeah so it's on a little bookshelf I
got a little bookshelf it's a nice
little spot
yeah one of the the wing things kind of
fell off I gotta like
nah yeah I gotta glue it damn
get us out of this podcast after my
boring story and wait that magic trick
do the watch all right okay everybody
here we go how the [ __ ] well now I built
it up right up how can I
I'm gonna McDonald's I'm not bigger
I can see the guy in the middle is
pretty rich you can see it through his
spicy eyes
not rich
here we go ready
I don't know if I can
it's a pretty it's a pretty pretty sexy
tree okay boom right right so you got
the watch here right wait oh let me get
the frame
see this hand right
see this hand over here look at the
watch but look at the hand but focus on
the watch
boom how did that come off my wrist bro
literally magic literally magic
right I hate you but look at the water
look at that [ __ ] sexy Seiko baby
come on gosh this is hilarious you know
they say men don't care like men don't
wear pink but like Pink's the [ __ ]
[ __ ] bro I love pink what do you mean
right I'm just saying like more men got
a whip
salad but yeah that's my that's my trick
guys built up three weeks neon to come
hope you liked it yeah
I hope neonicon never comes back
oh I love doing that you're so pissed
[ __ ] magic trick
oh I can show you a different magic
trick all right all right no see this
cloth right yeah it's uh it's a it's a
glass cleaner cloth
so that's nothing nothing all right I'm
gonna put it in my hand all right
welcome
put in my hand all right yeah blow on it
wait let me do the sexy Marilyn Monroe
um
blowing on sexy
wait I gotta turn this way
oh yeah all right ready you ready are
you ready ready
yeah yeah all right
your goddamn right you waited two weeks
for that you love it look at that just
sorry what a magic trick I've just
wasted 10 seconds
we've waited two weeks for that uh very
good
Theo what if that would have been fooled
no because every time every time when
after he bought that [ __ ] watch he's
like [ __ ] he calls me otter randomly all
right okay I gotta talk to you about
something he's like all right what is it
is it a is it a work thing is that yeah
it's important to Smart the barn like
and he calls me he's like can you turn
on your video you want to turn another
video
it's like all right what is it about uh
and then I turn on my videos like ah
look at this sesky ass watch baby shut
the [ __ ] up I can't remember what that
sounds about right that sounds about
right
uh worth it oh you're the worst huh you
saw you know when we did that the LA
trip right you know Don pops and he's
like oh hey guys I recorded something
just throw it into the video for the the
anime figurine challenge just throw it
in there it's gonna be really funny I'm
like okay so then I watch it and then
he's like guess what guys I bought a
watch and he's like freaking out again
I'm like yeah what's the contract though
baltic's uh answer to the Rolex Explorer
fun fact wow right A Little Indie micro
brand solid solid great Christmas is
near what are you getting what are you
guys getting anything you guys want to
buy yourself a gift oh
gonna buy yourself a watchdog uh I I do
but at this point like
nah I gotta like wait a bit good boy
well let's go extracted
very very smart
me uh let's see I want to get I want to
get a new laptop I want to get basically
I want to get a whole like you should
get a PC
you should just get a PC you should know
Griff don't buy [ __ ] talk to bobcat and
then like when you go out be like on the
phone and then he can literally like
help you I'll help you it's a lot of
work for him but like he's fine with it
okay as long as it's not dumb that song
it's not dumb I'm okay with helping you
out hey Tom's the worst here we go Dom's
literally the worst he asked me how to
turn on his thing for like 10 times at
the that's true he asked me the same
question 10 days in a row the same
[ __ ] things like Bobcat why is my
camera not on uh where's my mic not on
maybe you should check your microphone
Dom where's my camera not on wait yeah
now it's muscle memory so it's like is
it you just asked me before we started
the stream Dom no but that was a
different thing that was a different
thing wait I was like how do I turn my
camera on it's like uh maybe you should
check this ah there was a whole thing
and then the wires and then physics just
just didn't pan up but if you do need if
you want to buy it just uh hit me what
the budget is and we'll work it out that
way okay because there's an easy one if
you can just want a pre-built one just
[ __ ] uh should have bought one on
Black Friday honestly uh Brian I
probably should have done that that's
for sure
is living alone scary thinking about
moving out but these horror stories of
living alone freaking my decisions out
well
hmm
uh no uh it's not uh have you ever lived
alone Griffin
have I ever lived alone uh nope never
had to you know live with my parents uh
moved out to Ohio
and with family for like next few months
and then you know fiance girlfriend
fiance at the time she came with me so
I've always actually
you know then we got the house that we
got now
um we've always been no I've always had
somebody so oh [ __ ] I didn't know that
yeah
happy birthday apparently it was
yesterday
mine's on Monday
yeah it is okay tell me if you're here I
will send you those Monster energy
drinks as a bird no stop it's straight
no vote Thai Thai customs and [ __ ] it's
it's not worth it it's not worth it you
can't get anything from oh because
they'll like keep it in for ages and
then like demand some ridiculous charge
for it it's like why I don't buy shoes
like important [ __ ] it's not worth it
Energy Drinks like so much he talks
about it yeah
yes Dino Brando I did say Ohio I was out
there for a little while I did some uh
personal training type stuff did that a
while and then I did some like kind of
Dent with the Stars type thing not the
actual show but just you know
taught people how to do ballroom dance
and whatnot did that that was fun
see Brandon my birthday is in May
I'm a May Guy that's my I don't have my
birthday get a new camera
720px looks good on you well thank you
for that maybe I will get a new one this
is a good camera it's a good camera I
think is that the gato right oh yes the
gato yeah yeah
yeah that's better am I right it's true
uh I need to stretch actually I stood up
sorry sure you know I actually got a
camera similar to theirs it was an older
model but it didn't have the feature
that I needed so I actually so I brought
it back to like Best Buy at the time and
I was just like ah you told me like you
bought you bought it's like I bought
this don't buy that one return it right
now before we get your money back and
buy this one and then it was out of
stock for a long time
it was yeah so it happened I got what I
could get they actually are coming out
with a new one elgato's coming out with
a like a new apparently true 4K 60 frame
whatever web cameras like should be
upgrade I don't think oh really damn
yeah I think the thing is you just need
good lighting uh I just need to set up
your lighting and your camera a little
bit more maybe when I yeah I'll play
with a little more I'll go to your place
someday and I'll just set it up for you
we'll see what happens oh you should
guys you don't understand we've talked
about it before in like recorded
podcasts like Dom get some more lighting
and he's like
no I've got I paid like [ __ ] cash
money for these I got the big lights bro
the big stream of Lights fancy schmancy
type [ __ ] he's got he's got good
lighting I just I just gotta I just
gotta uh fiddle with the uh thing fiddle
with a little bit
fiddling that means you're gonna have to
video chat him again
I I literally probably have to fly over
just to uh yeah we'll make it a trip you
know we'll go out show you the streets
uh thank you all uh but no I seriously
thought you got a new camera since last
live it looked better uh must be the
lighting yeah
the first one he looked like [ __ ]
crap oh
it was awful I you know what I looked
into that it wasn't the
um Dom has got a 144p camera seem seems
professional they do have some kind of
weird camera no he was dissing though
is it does it not that bad no no I think
the lighting is just a bit dark
okay I noted very good yeah no um
funny yeah no my uh it was actually had
something to do with Discord actually
looked up some settings then they said
if you had problem streaming a video and
you're getting lags and stuff to
actually turn off a couple of settings
because we're using Discord to help this
all work and I turned off the settings
and it worked and I was like great so
that's kind of
sorry caught us in a bad time because
we're gonna dip hello yeah we are
getting ready to leave just a smidge
final words any final words uh I'll see
you guys next week
okay no do you guys have any final words
uh final words
um weeb King anime you're all my minions
I love you
um now I got nothing else
that's right thank you all yes
thank you check out the next week's
video or this week depending if I can
finish it this week
Pastor Bobcat is gonna refrain from
partying this weekend so he can get the
job done he's a professional
uh
Tom should talk about himself but the
thing is I'm the one who's uh pretty
late currently so I can't really talk
[ __ ] oh oh that's okay
you got stuff going on bro it's all good
we love you too
wait we have one question did the spicy
nerdy guy go to a fast food or what I
need to stretch my legs all right
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] I will ban you
what the [ __ ]
hey legendary we love you but listen
we're actually we're leaving very soon
week uh came back at the right time how
about next time you guys come here at
the right time you pee every Thursday
y'all okay yeah we're trying to do every
Thursday at whatever 10 p.m mango time
Thailand time whatever that is in the
globe every Thursday
all right every Thursday probably we're
not gonna do the one on uh
like almost new years all right
something right oh yeah I had a business
thing I had to do at that time
all right but you you have a business
thing yeah thank you everyone thank you
so much
uh next week like share our video next
time maybe we'll share the stream
together bye-bye guys let's check out
parasite all right exercise